FRIEDMAN: All right.
Welcome, everyone.
It is September 7th, 2022.
We're here in ActInf Livestream
number 48.1.
In the second discussion
on the paper, "Communication
as Socially Extended Active Inference:
An Ecological Approach
to Communicative Behavior."
Welcome to the Active Inference
Institute,
where we are a participatory
online institute
that is communicating,
learning and practicing
applied active inference.
This is a recorded
and an Archived livestream,
so please
provide us with feedback
so we can improve our work.
All backgrounds
and perspectives are welcome
and we'll be following
video etiquette for the livestream.
Head over to active inference
dot org
to learn
more about getting involved in different
learning groups
and projects at the Institute.
Well, we're here in stream number 48.1,
continuing our discussion
on communication, active inference,
ecological approaches and so on.
This is going to be a
really exciting discussion
and we're appreciative
of the first author joining us.
We'll jump
right in with some introductions
and then onto the discussion.
So if you're watching live, feel
free to write
any questions in the live chat.
And I know that on our side
we have a lot of things to explore.
And also,
of course,
looking forward
to learning more
and seeing where it goes.
So I'm Daniel.
I'm a researcher in California.
And I guess
the ecosystem of today is chaparral
because it's very warm where I am.
And so
I was thinking about how different
ecosystems and eco tones
might facilitate
different kinds of communication
in a regional way.
And I'll pass it to Dean.
TICKLES: I, I'm Dean.
I'm in the Rocky Mountains in
western Canada right now. And
it's it's
what we would do in Fahrenheit.
It's about
45 Fahrenheit this morning,
but it's going to work from up
to about 90.
So,
yeah, there's a bit of an ecology
going on around here, too.
I think
it's going to be
a really interesting day
because I think what we're going to do
is take this ecological approach
and lens and with
the background of everybody
here, we're going to really be able
to pull up a lot of different,
interesting things that otherwise
we would not pay attention to
if we only got
stuck on the transmission piece.
And I'll pass it down to Bleu.
KNIGHT: Hi, I'm Bleu.
I am a researcher in Sunny, beautiful
New Mexico
at the other end of the Rocky Mountains
from Dean.
Like, literally,
if you just go straight down, I'm
in the century to Christmas
and we are recovering here from a like
torrential summer of rain.
And I
think we're
I think like maybe
we're finally getting back to some sun.
It's starting to get hot now,
like finally.
So I think that the sun is is here
to stay for.
We still have a hot month,
I guess,
but the desert ecosystem
and the to our desert is special
and fun and always excites me.
And I'm interested to in this paper
and in
how it more applies broadly the
the communication
as compared to the vassal paper
like can we then apply it to animals
and also to like
maybe human animal interactions
and what those look like and maybe
not only cooperative communication
but also like competitive communication.
And I think,
I think
like extending this work into
those avenues is
interesting and exciting.
FRIEDMAN: Awesome.
Thank you, Bleu.
So, Remi, welcome and please
take it away.
Feel free to introduce yourself
and give any context on the paper.
TISON: All right. So thank you for having me.
I'm really pleased to see that
we will discuss our paper.
I'm Remi Tison. I'm a researcher
based in Montreal at UConn
and yeah, it's
it's sunny it's a nice day you're too.
And so yes
the paper was
an attempt to
to device a view of communication
that could be like a starting point
for ecological and in active approaches
to language and communication.
And the problem that we saw
is that in most
language sciences, like linguistics,
in the field of language,
in mainstream philosophy, in language
and in biology of communication,
most researchers,
most people end up at IQ automatically
a view of communication
in which communication is
essentially transmitting
information or transmission,
transmitting content
or an idea to another being.
So
usually like
in linguistic communication,
that would be like,
I have the belief
that it's a sunny day outside.
I say it's a sunny day outside.
And then by doing this,
I am transmitting to you
the belief
that it's a sunny day outside.
So that's the
basic view of communication,
the transmission view
that is
more or less adopted by everybody
in in linguistics and in
cognitive science.
But a lot of people at least,
and that's a view of communication
that is problematic
from an active
and ecological perspective
because it relies on the notion
of content
and the notion of representation
to transmit a content,
I must have a representation in my head
and then I can transmit it to you
so that you can entertain
this representation in your head.
But as is quite well known
in active and ecological approaches
to cognition,
I reject the notion of representation,
the notion,
the notion of content
as basic building block of cognition.
So the transmission view is a problem
from an active ecological view.
And so
what we tried to do
was to develop a view of communication
from which ecological
and active approaches
could start to understand language
and communication without having to rely
on the notion of content
or representation.
So that's like
the basic motivation of the paper.
That's what we were trying to do
and we thought that
active and friends and
especially its ecology
interpretation could be useful
for doing that.
And,
and yet
the thing that you mentioned, Bleu.
Yeah,
the aim was to devise
a view of communication
that could be perfectly general,
so that could be applied to
animal communication,
maybe communication
between cells at the, at,
the, at the more,
at the more small scale level
and eventually
maybe communication
between groups
at the more at a larger scale so that
the view to
the attempt
was to produce a view of communication
that is perfectly general
and that can be precise and
along the way.
So that we can, for instance,
precise the conception of communication
to apply it
to cooperative communication,
for instance,
which is the kind of communication
that is characteristic of human
communicative interaction,
and that was treated
notably in the cell paper to which you
alluded to.
So that's the aim of the paper.
And so because of its generality,
it's the paper that is really
in a way superficial because
it's it really treats
a lot of topics really quickly.
But that was like
a big road map
for a view of communication
that could be used
by ecological and active researchers.
So that was essentially
what we tried to do in this paper.
FRIEDMAN: Awesome.
And just one more follow up question.
We often asked would be,
how did you come to use
active inference?
What about the collaboration
or your direction
led to the fusion of these approaches?
Where you studying
communication more broadly
and came across
active inference or vice versa?
TISON: Yeah.
So earlier in my in my academic career,
so to speak,
I was really more in
Philadelphia of mind
to have more
of a philosophical background
and not really in cognitive science.
So that's where I became acquainted with
like issues, about content,
about meaning, etc..
And then I came to
Cam worked with quality,
which is really more center
than philosophy
of cognitive science
and was really interested in predictive
processing theories
and eventually in active inference
framework
because of its
link with predictive processing.
So coming at you can with well,
I really became acquainted with these,
with these ideas, with these frameworks
and that's where I linked these,
these new frameworks
with my earlier interests
in language and communication that came
from my background
in philosophy of mind.
So that's kind of how it happened.
And talking with Clive and the community
of researchers at Education
who is
really using the predictive processing
and active inference frameworks,
and that's how it all came together.
FRIEDMAN: Awesome. Well,
many places to pick up, perhaps,
Dean, first, if you'd like to.
TICKLES: Well, okay,
I'll start with the question.
If I'm if we're going to
if we're going to take an an activist
approach to this,
we're going to look at at
what communication is
through that philosophical approach and
and take all that active inference
affords in terms of of opening up
what communication is,
maybe.
I mean,
could you talk a little bit
about how people who
want to argue that there is no content?
What, how then what,
how could we then describe
our experiences,
the things that we've played out,
the things
that we're going to play towards?
But mostly what I'm curious about is
the things that have been played,
because we've got a record of that.
We don't have to call it content.
But I've had a lot of conversations
with a lot of people
who live in the in activist
thinking community, and they
they come up,
they twist
a whole bunch of things around,
but they really have a hard time
coming up with an argument that says,
my experiences
aren't something, some thing.
So maybe you could talk
a little bit about the.
TISON: Yeah, so that's a good question.
I think that's one of the answers
that I could provide
is that from my perspective,
there are some people in ecological
and active
circles who refuse all reference
to content.
This content doesn't exist at all.
But that's not my perspective.
From my perspective, content is just not
at the basic level of cognition.
And it's like
it's kind of
I don't know
if you're familiar
with the work of Hutto and Mayan.
There are
these are radical and activists,
and they claim
that their content is not like
at the fundamental level, it's
something that gets added up
once there are a particular kind
of social normative practices
that can give rise to content.
So that that's my view.
I think that we can describe the basic
cognitive functioning
of organisms
and animals and in many cases humans
without the use of the notion of content
of the notion of representation.
I think that we can do that.
But at some point in our in our
in our social interactions,
there are multiple things that
that
that can
happen that will give rise
to a content to representation.
And that's that's a complicated story.
That's something
that I might come back to later on.
But the idea is that content is not
at the basic level.
It's not something
that we can presuppose
in a theory of communication
and something that can be explained
by a theory of communication.
But it's not something that is
that can be taken
as something that can explain.
It's something that has to be explained,
so to speak.
I don't know if I'm clear
so we can,
I think, use the notion of content
to characterize
the kind of experience, the kind of
phenomena that you allude to, but
this notion must be
it must not be taken as granted.
That's that the view that I take.
And I think there are some ways
to explain how content
arrives on the scene, but
it's not
something that can be taken
as granted in a theory
area of communication.
And that's what
I'm critiquing in this paper.
It's like
in traditional transmission view
of communication,
people, principles,
that there is content,
that there is representation,
and communication is defined
as the transmitting
of this content, of this representation.
What I'm saying is that
representation is not an explosion,
something that
that can be used
as this based all explanatory notion.
It's something we have to
describe communication
without the use of this notion
and then with various tools
of social interaction
and particularly social
normative practices,
we can explain out there
that our content can then arise
so that that's
I can
if you want to
give more detail on that front.
But that's my, my, my $0.02. So
content exists.
It's not just
at the basic level of communication.
FRIEDMAN: Awesome.
That reminds me of
and to to stay on our philosophy
wavelength.
The difference between the explaining
and them and the exponents.
So just quoting Wikipedia
and explanation
them is a sentence
describing a phenomena
that is to be explained,
and the explanations are
the sentences
are adduced
as explanations of that phenomena.
And so it's a very interesting
difference
among these theoretical views
and framings,
which I'm
sure we'll be able to unpack
a lot of implications of that content
as a phenomena
or a descriptive category
sign or symbol.
We can have many ways
of even describing what that is.
However, under the transmission view,
you're suggesting
that content is seen
as what is able to explain
different phenomena like communication
or cooperative communication,
no matter how far out you go in the sub
discussions, content is doing something
to explain.
Whereas in the radical
and activist approach,
radical meaning from the root.
So with an activism at the root,
that doesn't mean
that there couldn't be a branch
that summarizes and reflects content,
but it's something that is explained
through an active means
rather than something
that we're going
to put like the cart before the horse
and then use this semantic content
representation view
and the transmission associated with it
to then try to explain in activism.
TICKLES: Deem
Yeah, I think I,
I'm, I'm on the same page
as both of you.
I, I take an example and in 2019 I'm
walking up
the street, Rue Saint Tony,
and I'm heading to the patisserie
and I don't have any first
hand experience with that,
but once I arrive there
and I one of those, those chocolate
pastries, now all of
a sudden I have content.
So it wasn't that I had content first,
even when I was looking at the map
and walking up from UK and
past all the bars and
and on a beautiful fall day,
I had the content once
I experienced something first.
But I also can't deny
that there was an aspect of that
that wasn't limited just to the moment
of all of the actions that I took
walking up the street.
So
if we're going to look at an ecology
and as I said in my first question,
if we're going to use
active inference as the lens,
the situational analysis method,
I don't know how we can draw up content,
but I do think the timing of when we
see it as the important thing or the
the central aspect
of what communication is,
I don't think it
destroys the fact that we still have it.
It's just
when does it matter
in that in that continuum.
So yeah.
And by the way, thank you
for just reminding me of that.
That trip in to Montreal in 2019 before
all the
tech broke loose with all these viral
things, was beautiful.
Time.
FRIEDMAN: I also went to Montreal in 2019.
Very cool to.
KNIGHT: Yeah.
I am curious
about the difference between
or maybe there's no difference
or how can we
clarify the difference between content
and context?
FRIEDMAN: Yes, great question.
What do you think for me?
TISON: Okay, so content is
essentially
something that as accuracy conditions.
So the idea of content is it's
something that can be false or true.
It's something that can be or more
generally something
that can be satisfied or not satisfied.
So for instance,
usually we'll say that
our propositional attitude of content.
So for instance, when I have a belief,
my belief as a content
and this content can be true or false
or for instance,
if I believe that it's sunny outside,
I have the belief that it is
sunny outside in the content,
it is sunny outside.
It can be true or false
and it's sunny outside
that then my my belief is true.
So that's the basic idea of content.
It's something that is attached to
our mental states
and it's usually associated associated
with the notion of representations.
There are
complex debates to be out there,
but that's the idea of content.
It's something that it's like.
It's like,
yeah, something
that as
conditions of correction
in which it can be correct or incorrect.
And so that's content and context
in in the
I don't know if you
mean in general
or in the specific way
in which we use it in the paper.
KNIGHT: So
how you use it in the paper?
TISON: Yeah.
So context is a set of elements
that are relevant to the and
to the, to a joint action.
So that's how we use it. A context.
A context of action
in particular in the paper
we're talking about joint action.
So when two people or more people
are performing a joint action,
they're doing something together.
There are going to be some elements,
some events,
some objects of the environment
that will be relevant
on which some action has to be
done in order to advance
the joint action for the context is like
this structured
a special temporarily structured
set of elements
on which action has to be taken
to progress the joint action.
So that's the notion of context
that we use in the paper.
I don't know if
if that certifies them well.
KNIGHT: So it implies like,
like the set of elements is therefore
also content. Is that true.
TISON: In that in the
paper we we don't think that it is
my describing it
as a set of elements is a content
full description
because I'm talking about it
and there's a content to the sentence
of me
saying that,
that there's a set of elements,
but the set itself,
the thesis that we are pushing for
in the paper is that it can be
it can appear in that field.
Those affordances of an organism
without it having to represent it.
So that's where that's
what we are going to in
ecological psychology.
There's we're working on the notion
of a field of affordances.
So it's like the set,
the structure and set of affordances
to which an organism is sensible.
And it's like there
there's some elements that will
drive its action
differentially depending on
various internal factors.
And this sensibility of an organism
to its environment
doesn't have to be characterized
in terms of content.
If we believe that
the ecological psychologists
who developed this notion
so this set of elements
appears in a field of affordances
and these
these organisms
who are sensible
to their field of affordances
not have to entertain
their representation
of this set of element.
They're just sensible to their field
of affordances.
And that's how they respond
to these sets of elements
of their environment.
KNIGHT: So like I maybe like
when you talk about content,
maybe that is what needs
to actually be clarified.
Like so content is specifically
some kind of semantic representation
or semiotic representation
and said something that is explicit
but like can you,
can you give me an example of the
what would be an element
in like a set of elements like how,
how is that also not like content?
TISON: Yeah, these are obviously
complex questions, but
yeah,
typically and that's
our audience is a relation
between an element of the environment
and an action capacity of an organism
and the, the,
the thesis that is taken by an
ecological psychologist,
not everybody will agree with that.
But is that
the perception of affordances and does
not need
the mediation of a representation?
You can directly be sensible
to a certain pattern.
I've been there, for instance, in the
in the in the energy array around you
and you respond
to this pattern of energy
by, for instance,
taking the foreign dunes
that is specified
by this pattern of energy.
And you don't
as it's
not necessary to have a representation
of the far dense
to which you're sensible,
it's something that you can
directly perceive.
And that's
that's like a central idea
of ecological psychology.
Some people will disagree with
that will say
that you cannot be sensible
to in that far dense
if you don't represent it.
So that that's
something that you can argue for.
But there is a
lot of ecological psychologists
who believe
that you can be directly sensible
to affordances
of your environment
just by responding to the
the energy array
that is in your environment
without needing
to represent this effort.
And so
in doing that,
they say that we don't need
the notion of content or representation
to characterize
the way
in which an organism is responsive
to the affordances of its environment.
And that's what we
we presuppose in this paper.
But obviously there are disagreements
to be had there.
There are people
obviously you think that
if an organism is to
act on
its environment,
it has to be to have it
representation of its environment
in order to act correctly.
So that's obviously
something that can be defended too
well. Great.
KNIGHT: Thank you so much.
No, that's super helpful.
Thanks.
It makes me think of a tug of war game
or just two people pulling on a rope.
They're engaged in joint action,
which is how action and activism
are placed
at the center of the account of context.
One individual pulling the rope.
They might be thinking or thinking
that they think any number of things.
But through
the field of affordances
being shaped through the regularities
and the,
I think, arrays of energy
that you described in the speech
that is going to alter
the field of affordances of someone
on the other side of the rope,
and that could be mediated
through their appropriate perception.
FRIEDMAN: Or maybe the rope is now not graspable,
but it was graspable previously.
None of that requires a symbolic
or even necessarily semantic component
to be transmitted
along with the rope pole.
Maybe they had a pre play and they said
two tugs means this
and three means that.
And that can also reflect planning
to communicate.
However, in the act of communication,
as we're exploring, we're
putting action
and the embodiment
in the environment as primacy
and then seeing certain types
of cognitive agents
as being able to develop representation
like properties
on top of some physical regularities
in the niche din.
I mean,
TICKLES: what would you think of this idea
if you if I were to
we haven't defined ecology
here in this conversation,
but if if someone like me
came along to you and said,
can we define it as both
a process, ecology as process
and an ecology as a as a product?
Would you push back on that, on that
ability to see it to two ways
and then I guess on top
on the general level
to Bleu's question then can can we,
can we see it
as content and context, this idea,
this placeholder of ecology,
if we keep it on that general level,
can we have our cake and eat it too?
TISON: Yeah.
So ecology here
really refers to something specific.
It's not ecology
in general, like in
the branch of biology
when in in
so that you are connected science.
When we talk about
ecological psychology, it's a particular
movement that became that
that began with the work of the
of Gibson
in the fifties, sixties and seventies.
And it's an approach to psychology
that states that the
recognition of animals is the matter
of its direct relation
with its environment
and is a matter of
the kind of skills
that are exhausted by this animal
in its environment.
And the
central notion of ecological psychology
is the notion of affordances
and therefore dense is a possibility
of action.
It's a relation
between an element of the environment
and a skill
that can be exercised on this element
of the environment.
And the thesis of Gibson
and all the ecological psychologies
that followed after that is that
organisms and
animals
primarily perceive affordances
in their environment.
They don't perceive objects,
they don't perceive
events or properties.
What they perceive
first and foremost,
first and foremost is
possibilities for action.
And they are
pushed and pulled
by their environment in various way
and responsive to their environment
to take some affordances
and don't
not take
some other affordances and that.
So that's like in a constant interaction
with their environment,
organisms will respond
to these affordances and do some,
do some things and we'll be attracted by
some affordances will be pushed
by some other affordances,
and that's how an organism interacts
with its environment. So that's ecology.
It really refers to that,
that body of ideas that came
from the work of Gibson
in ecological psychology.
There are
obviously links with ecological ecology
more broadly in the in the
as a branch of biology,
but it's really specifically the
like the this this set of ideas
linked to
ecological psychology and Gibson's work.
TICKLES: Do you think that
that what you just described
the possibility
could be for people like yourself
both a product and a process,
is that possibility
something that can be categorized
two different ways at once?
TISON: So that's a good question.
You mean like a.
TICKLES: Is it a category error
to say it's only a process?
That would be another way
of asking the same questions.
TISON: I think that ecological psychologists
would more
preferred the description of the
the interaction of an organism
with its environment
in terms of process,
because the organisms is always
changing through its interaction
with its environment.
And obviously
the organism is also changing
the environment control
as is described in
in active insurance
accounts of niche construction.
So there's always an evolving
interaction in which the organisms
gain skills
and the environment is transformed.
So the field of
affordances is like never static,
so it can never really be described
as a product.
I don't know if that's
and that can
that answer is a bit for your question.
TICKLES: Well, are there other products
within what you just described?
So for example, if I
if I'm an organism,
I've had experiences
and I can now use those experiences
to continue my process.
Are those those things that
I've experienced,
are they do
they just have to stay
in the same category
as now processed as in as in past
or have they solidify?
Because I can't go back
and change my history per se,
I can build off of it.
But those are pretty absolute.
Now, this
this sentence that I'm getting out
is going to have a record
that I can't I can't erase.
So are those things products now?
And in the enacting of whatever
I've decided
I want to focus on
in terms of possibility.
TISON: I may be I just say something quick.
Maybe when you you take
like a definite time slice
of an evolving organism,
you can see that at that point
there's a product that can be defined.
You can say, okay, at that point there's
this set of abilities,
this set of skills,
this set of experiences
that can be attributed to this animal.
So there is a product at that point,
but if you take the organism
evolution like it's
in its entirety,
there is always changing.
So
it's something it's always a process
in truth, there's always a process.
But if you you
you freeze frame,
maybe you can say, okay, at that point
there's this.
And then that
is a product of the of the,
the interaction.
But I don't know if I answered
correctly your question,
but that's that would be my, my idea.
TICKLES: Yeah,
you are answering and that's great.
I'm just trying to get in my mind
if we're going to talk about relativity
and I know that I step into a river and
step out
and then step into it
a second time,
I'm not stepping into the same river.
So what
gives me the affordances
to realize that difference?
Is it a product?
Is it
the first step
is that
first time I went in now a product
because I can't go back and change it,
I can move off of that
and see the relative,
the relative distance
or the relative time.
But I don't know how we do
processing with our product.
That's, I guess, what I'm asking.
FRIEDMAN: One quick thought on that
is that product doesn't necessarily
mean singular final static.
There are working products
that can be versioned,
which digital files have helped us see.
And then also we could say that
the past is produced,
but also it's reproduced
when it's remembered,
when it's brought back together,
and even
in the directions
you point to
towards the end of the paper,
with what kinds
of empirical neurophysiological accounts
are helping bolster
the ecological claim,
the realization
that memories
are not being accessed as static files
but are recreated contextually
and relived is an interesting
angle.
Yes, Bleu.
KNIGHT: So the recreation of memories
contextually, like in
dreams, is really interesting
because it's like the recreation
and also like recombination
in in a different context.
And just before we leave
context entirely,
I guess, I think I have a hard time with
all of this
because even a field of affordances
has content, right?
Like,
like I can go fly a kite
if it's windy outside.
Like,
I have a set of actions
that I can choose from.
And I think
because we have to talk about it
in a way that's semantic, it's difficult
to like experience
my field of recordings
because I'm a human.
And not only that, like I'm
a very verbal human.
So so
I think that there's there's like that.
But but we
even the field of
affordances has content.
But but I realized that, like,
it's the mental representation
aspect that is not
that is
the distinction
between content and context.
And I just want to point to
the quantum paper
where we have
the quantum reference frames
and crisp fields for our next reality
that we did on the livestream.
I think number 40 and live stream
number 17.
And just it's it's not possible
to have
a full contextual alignment here.
And it makes me think of in the paper
how you were describing like
there's this person
on one end of the beat
of the tug of war,
and then there's another person
on the other end of the tug of war.
And then there's actually
the tug of war itself.
And I just wonder about like,
what is the
the so person has their context, person
B has their context.
What is the context of the tug of war
itself? Like it's it's another entity.
Anytime you have this like interaction.
And this is something that I've said
to Daniel before,
like you have a relationship
with a person,
you have a set of communication
with the person.
Like that's its own thing.
Like that has to be like
loved, protected, nurtured.
Like you have to keep it up.
It has to
like like it has to
undergo like altarpieces
it has to self-assemble,
like it's its own entity.
And I wonder about modeling in that way.
Like, like if I model my communication,
like there's
me and the person
and then the interaction
or the collective behavior or whatever
it may be, I don't know.
I just it's I've been thinking about it
and yeah, that's all.
FRIEDMAN: It's like a view from the bottom
or inside or however of communication
where there's two entities
and a partially aligned frame.
And then there's also a view
where it is just one thing,
albeit maybe with partial information
encapsulation,
but it still becomes one thing.
And then is that one thing atomic
even though it contains
divisions and partitions as well.
Remi on that or anywhere you want to go.
TISON: Yeah I think
blew your interventions that were really
are really really interesting
so far
for did the first thing that you said
I think I know those are the 2
to 2 to
like remove are
are a bit of describing things
in terms of content
because we have language
and we
describe things in terms of contents.
But it's something that has
been remarked by really, really
by a phenomenological phenomenology
that's like Merleau-Ponty and and
they are that our primary
contact with the world is not some like
a description, it's
not like a representation
and it's not like a
reflexive consciousness.
It's a free reflexive consciousness.
And in your day
to day interaction
with your environment,
you're not using this kind of language
like description
to experience your environment.
Like if you're playing a sports
and like for instance
with you're playing soccer and you,
you see like a pass that you can make,
you're not
reflexively thinking that, Oh,
you could make that pass.
It's like a push or a pull
in a field that in
their field kind of thing.
And that's how we, we experience.
And the second where us humans,
especially we,
we begin to
think about our experience,
then we cannot help but describe it
in terms of content,
in terms
of a representation that we entertain
in the linguistically
with the
linguistic means,
but in our free
reflexive engagement
with the environment.
That's the
thesis of the economic logics
and the ecological psychology.
It's really just a push
and pull
from the environment
that drives us in different directions.
And we don't have this kind of
reflexive consciousness,
this kind of representation
on which we rely to describe and
understand it
with these linguistic means.
So I think that's really the difficulty
that we have of late in
getting to this pre
reflexive consciousness
when we are so used to this again
that we describe something,
we are describing it
in terms of content.
So we have it's hard to say, oh,
there is no content
when we talk about it,
we are invoking content automatically.
So yeah, there's a difficulty there.
And about
the autonomy
of the dynamic of an interaction
that's something
that's really, really interesting.
And there's been
a great work on this by a
is it Kelsey Paolo
I don't know if you're familiar
is working is an activist researcher
is working on language too and I am
I have been really inspired by his work
and he's
describing situations where like
there are two people interacting
and these two people as goals
that are aligned.
But because of the particular dynamic
of the interaction,
these goals don't come to fruition.
For instance,
you're walking in the in the corridor
in there somewhere
and you're facing somebody.
And both of you want to like
fluidly like pass each other, but
you're both trying to go for on one side
and then on one side
and you're blocking each other
that you're trying to
achieve the same goal,
which is individually
passing past each other.
But because of a dynamic
that arises from your
interaction, you're
you cannot achieve this, this goal.
So there
there's really like this
autonomous dynamic
at the interaction
that is really important.
And I don't think
obviously that's something that
that we wanted to put in the paper
because we're talking about
interactive, dynamic, dynamic systems.
But I don't think
that I have succeeded in
translating this in the way
we think of shared field of affordances
because I,
I define shared filter
avoidance is as the subset
that is common to both
individual fields of affordances.
But I think that neglects this point,
this autonomy of
the field of affordances
that is shared in the interaction.
I don't know
if I'm being clear,
but I define the shared
field of affordances
as a product of the combination
that a combination
of the two individual
fields of affordances.
But it seems that there's
a lack of autonomy
in the shell
field that
I don't know how to account for.
FRIEDMAN: That makes me think of the ants case
where one nest may might be able to
grab a single seed and carry home.
So that would be compatible with a view
on communication
shaping the field of affordances
because it modifies
the capacity
for another nest
made to pick up that seed
because it's been moved
doesn't need to have any
representational content,
although especially when
we're linguistically describing
it does so
definitely want to come back to that.
Then there's this
seed grabbing ability
which is predicated on
a lower level of audience,
like the ability
to grasp with the mandibles.
And that lower level of audience enables
true joint action
like multiple nest mates
working together
to drag something bigger home,
but dragging something
bigger isn't in the fore,
and so even exists
at the single decimate level.
So there's like shared affordances
and joint action
at the level of what we can both do.
And then
there's also this very interesting
higher level view
where perhaps novel affordances
become accessible, but then whom
or to what
or when do these special affordances or
maybe nested
system affordances come into play?
And how will we mediate the the handoff
or like the way
that those different levels
of affordances
come into relevance or out of relevance,
Bleu.
KNIGHT: So in terms of that modeling,
the field of affordances
like it changes through time.
And this is why I like
I was thinking about
a competition
like in a tug of war between two people.
Both of them have the appearance to win
or there could be a tie, right?
But like it's a potential opportunity
for either one to win,
but only one can be the winner.
And so then one person winning,
like by default, you know, makes
it makes the other person lose.
And so this
this field
of avoidance, of thinking through
time is really interesting
and I think very broadly applicable
for modeling all kinds of processes.
TISON: Yeah, that's true.
And the idea about
the collective
affordances, there's
been some interesting,
interesting work on that
and clearly some organisms like ants
don't perceive collective affordances.
They perceive
is they perceive something,
they perceive
their individual affordances
and collectively level.
There's the the taking of this
higher level
affordances, this collective affordances
of our dance.
But they don't perceive individually,
probably
I don't think they do perceive
individually the audience.
But some organisms such as humans,
I think because we have
maybe a deeper generative of something,
we are able to
perceive some collective
affordances because we're
sensible to them.
For instance,
if I'm moving with a friend,
I can perceive that
a couch
is unmovable by me,
but I can perceive it as movable by us.
And then I can see like, Oh,
we could move this couch together
because I perceive it
as something that can be acted upon,
not just by me, but with somebody else.
And then I have a perception,
it appears in my individual
feed of our dance
as a collective for dance.
But that's different from the, the,
the ants who
achieve a collective action,
but without having the perception
their field of individual feeling,
of affordances
of this collective audience.
FRIEDMAN: That's awesome.
It makes me think of the human capacity
to have counterfactuals
and speculative
realism on teams and projects like, Hey,
everybody here, we could do X.
So there's the ability to communicate
semantically and representational
anywhere needed
plausible
narratives or little sub niches.
New things can be suggested and arise
that are specifically
about shared or collective affordances.
And then additionally,
there are special names for when we take
individual level affordances
that have consequences
on other levels of decision
making, like there might be
a multisig wallet
in cryptography
or a voting system in democracy
where an individual's affordances
like to pull the lever
or to fill in a box
or to assign a transaction,
and then it's being engaged in
specifically because there's knowledge
if 100 people do this,
then this performance
is going to happen.
So it seems like there's many cases
where we do
our mandible closing
the kind of lower level individual task,
also with an explicit knowledge
and a communicated knowledge around
how someone's individual actions will
influence group
outcomes that could be like
weakly emergent,
like merely
submitting the affordances
taken by individuals
as well as
strongly emergent
or more strongly
emergent in the sense
that there's, there's nothing different
about anyone's pulling lever and voting,
but there are phase transitions
and dynamics that can be like top down
deep.
TICKLES: Yes.
So when we have these experiences
and they are
kind of absolute in the sense that they
they've happened, they've occurred and
whether we can recall them or not,
they they seem to have
some kind of an effect
on this relativity piece and
and the relationship piece.
I don't think it matters whether we
see Newton on one side and then
Chris Fields
and an Einstein on the other,
that the bottom line is, is that to
what Daniel was just saying,
the possible happens
when we
don't get stuck on
what's the gauge
of the transmission line,
but what does that now allow us to do?
So how do we move from the absolutes,
the modeling piece to the process piece,
the things that are out there
that are have not happened yet,
that are still in
that possibility category.
And now we're going to use communication
not just to narrow
down to the workbench.
The ontology, which Daniel and I are
our fast friends,
except when it comes
to the specifics of ontology,
the generalities of that,
and the potential impossibility
of that, really,
maybe you can talk to us a little bit
about that from the ecological lens.
TISON: Yeah, that's a really good question.
I think the one interesting thing
about like collective
and shared affordances is I think they
they are learned
in the same way that we learned
individual affordances.
So for instance,
how do we learn how would we
we we learn to perceive enough audience.
We learn to perceive in that audience.
We I think we gain a skill.
When we gain
a particular skill,
we then can perceive in the
over environment,
the situations
where we can apply the skill.
So for instance,
when we're really young, we can like
I guess we can
then maybe crawl a little bit.
So we know where surfaces
can be crawled upon
and we can grab things.
So we perceive
where things can be grabbed.
And so we start from this
like basic skills
and then we explore our environment.
We do some things that we, we, we're
gaining some abilities
and when we do that,
probably a little bit by trial
and error,
we, we begin to perceive some
higher level affordances can
because we can do
some more complex things.
And so our field of affordances
deepens and become more
it becomes more complex
as our set of skills
becomes more complex.
But I think that interacting
with others, with others
and so sorry for my, my accent,
it's not really good.
I, I didn't want to say interacting with
the animal others.
So yes.
So when we interact with others
we are also learning
to do some particular things.
For instance,
if I tried to
to pick something up alone,
I might not be strong enough to do it.
So I don't have the skills.
So I don't perceive that for dense.
But if in some cases
I picked something up
and I see something, somebody else
picking it up with me
and we succeed in listing it
and then I've gained the ability
to see that
with somebody else I can lift the stick,
but it's not a different,
different kind of learning.
And in that case,
from the kind of learning
that I apply
when I'm learning individual skills,
it's just that interacting
with your environment,
you acquire skills,
somebody sometimes with some
somebody else, sometimes not.
And you
understand
how you can apply these skills
in your environment
and then you
navigate your field
affordances accordingly.
So how you perceive
a possibility is about,
Oh, you have to learn
to do some things in the past.
And then because of this learning,
you perceive situations
as affording these of actions.
They can be individual,
but in communication
they are
usually about what others can do
and what we can do with others.
And that's how you perceive
like the possibilities that can be
that can be
brought upon,
that can be done
with with the person
with which you're interacting.
But I don't know if that held.
But that's how I see it.
TICKLES: From a, from a modeling standpoint.
If you
if you move away from the constraints
and you look at the emancipation
and the freedom piece, it
obviously becomes combinatorial,
the explosive very,
very quickly,
because it can go off in many,
many directions.
As a for example, as Daniel
alluded to
and we started today's live stream,
this could go down many different paths.
So he left it open.
He left the freedom aspect in.
And so I was curious
what you think about.
So when we do leave that in,
when we do move out of the laboratory
or we do move away from the mechanics
which you were just describing,
and give our attention over to the
the freedoms piece of it without without
immediately assuming, oh, well,
we're going to start modeling now
because this is just going to
blow up on us.
I was wondering what you were thinking,
what you're thinking is around
that in terms of communication
as a platform for the possible?
TISON: Yes.
So the idea of communication is,
is that the role
it plays in interaction is
is a constraint.
It's a constraint
of the
on the set of possible action
that can be achieved.
So the idea is that the what
communication achieves
it helps to limit the kind
the scope of affordances
that will be salient at a given moment.
It's like you will center
like the shared field of affordances
around a certain set
or a certain affordances.
And this will limit
this will restrict the set
of affordances that will be
considered or
that can
be acted upon
by the individual participants.
So that's the role that I don't know
if that helps,
but that's how communication works.
I think in interaction
that everybody does it
in the dynamical systems terms.
If the idea was that
it allows
to create interpersonal synergies
in order to achieve the joint goals
of the interaction,
that was the suggestion in the paper.
So for instance, two people
being together in a in a room,
they can be a lot,
they can do a lot of thing.
There's like an almost infinite
set of affordances
that are open to them.
But if one of the people in the room,
like, goes
to the couch and see like couch
or manifestly tries to lift it,
then what is
what is conveyed for 2 to 3?
Take the transmission view idiom.
What is conveyed or what
to the effect that it
as it will augment the salience
of the sylvian of the audience,
of taking the couch,
and then this would restrict
the set of affordances
that are open,
that are salient in the shared field,
and then the other person will like,
see, okay, that's what we're doing now.
And they're going to
take the couch together
and list it and bring it.
So so that's the role of communication
is there's a whole set of affordances
open at any moment.
And what communication does it restricts
and it constrains
this set of affordances in order to
better achieve that, the joint goals
of interaction,
that's what we tried to do
in the
in the paper
to understand cooperative communication.
TICKLES: You touched on
an important
difference, though, between is
and if so, what is does
actually put pretty strong
what we kind of guardrails constraints.
But if I ask what if
I haven't
put a constraint
on something
I would look now
at the counterfactual and the possible
and I haven't said
that the first
the first person that answers back to me
is going to necessarily be
now the new constraint.
The whole point it
if is the possible right
and it is the freeing up
and it's the whiteboard moment
and you know all of this.
So again, I
in the context of this paper,
what the is part of
it is in terms of joint action.
But is there a what
is there a place in your research
or the if within the same arguments
that you're.
I believe that there is
but you didn't speak as clearly to them
as you did to the is parts.
The constrained parts.
TISON: Yes.
So the
I think what
you're talking about here is the
the the
communication about like future
or counterfactual situation.
That's what
that's what you're talking about.
The key. Yeah.
So what's
what we, we tried to do in the paper
is we introduce the notion
of a simulation
of a field of affordances.
And that's where we're
we're then
thing really closely
with like the notion of representation
because our idea
is that the representation of AI
and therefore it is like
it's like a fine, fine line to tread.
But
so, so
there's this notion
of a simulation of enough audience
feel some
sufficiently cognitively complex
organisms such as humans
and probably some primates can
can produce
a simulation of enough audience
that will enter in this year
hierarchical for dense competition.
So you can like activate enough audience
that is not immediately present
in order to affect
your current
field of audience to a, to, to, to, for,
for instance,
go towards this simulation of
does that based on the work
of Paul Chozick,
which is at at Montreal
and there's work on
for a dance competition.
And he argues that
a lot of
of the phenomena
linked to cognitive control
so such as the executive function
and this kind of thing
and working
memory can be understood
as these these effects of, of,
of affordances at higher levels
that will constrain
the their lower levels
of the field of affordances
in order, for instance, to act
accordingly to the desire level
for this.
So the example,
the example that she gives
is, for instance,
suppose that there is a monkey
on the, on a branch
that like sees a little berry
just, just beside it.
So there's the dance
of eating the berry.
But suppose that there's
an apple
which is a bigger fruit, a bigger prize
further down on the on the branched
and the monkey
as the understanding that there's a
in this apple for there there
you can
with this
this simulation of the dance
of eating this apple.
I your level
also like if I do that if I go there
I will get this apple
this simulation of a
not for a dance at a higher level
will constrain
with diminish
the salience of this immediate
so sedation that and it will help him to
like ignore this in the immediate berry
and it will
continue on the branch
in order to get to the bigger
through to the apple.
So there's like the basic idea of how
the simulation of affordances can play
like a cognitive control
role in order to constrain our behavior
according to further goals,
like in, in the future,
future situation.
So that
that's the idea
on which
we, we speak about it really,
really quickly in the paper
because it's already a really big paper.
But that's an important point.
And that's the key to understanding that
communication about future
and the counterfactual situation.
We talk about it in the last section.
It's the displacement
or did the absence reference discussion.
So the idea
how can we talk about things
that are not immediately present
in the special temporal sense?
And the idea is
that we can activate
shared simulations of affordances.
So I can speak about in affordances
that an audience
that is not immediately present,
but it can affect our
our shared field of audience
and it can drive our behavior
toward this audience, for instance,
even if it's not immediately present.
But, yes,
this poses the question of is
are these simulations
of affordances, representations?
I'm not I'm on the fence
on this question.
But if they are, they are probably like
action oriented representations
that we may be.
Would be acceptable
to an activist,
an ecological psychologist
sorry for my really long
and so that's something
that something
that I've really thought about a lot.
FRIEDMAN: Price Yeah.
You want to add anything?
Ah there's a few ways to go.
KNIGHT: So I'm going to go ahead
and take it away.
FRIEDMAN: All right.
Well, one
interesting connection
with active inference.
You mentioned there's nested affordances
is including ones that include that are
plausible.
So that reminded me a lot of the
attention and metacognition
as mental action,
which we explored in Livestream
25 with Sanford Smith at ALS Paper,
where the same way
that at the kernel layer
of the partially observable
Markov decision process
or however we're doing active modeling
at the most basil kernel layer,
those pies, those policy selections
and those ease, those affordances
have to do with the level of affordances
that is embodied,
like the actual actions
that the eyes are taking
in the ocular motor case
or the actual direction
that's taken
left or right in a TMS example.
And then nested modeling
is using an analogous
graphical structure where policies
of nested levels reflect, attention
being paid to various lower level,
lower
levels of that
hierarchical architecture.
So there could be
one lever they can go left and right
and one that can go up and down.
And then there's a higher level decision
like which of these two levers
should I be paying attention to and how
where am I of
which left are I'm paying attention to
and so on.
So I think
the paper itself does not present any
formal isms,
but there's extensive
linking to work in active inference
and also to really resonate ideas
that are in a non slash pre
active inference framing
that are immediately compatible
like nested levels of affordances.
The distinction
between
the primacy of the bodily affordances,
but also for certain cognitive systems,
the existence of what appear
to be cognitive affordances
and the desire to model those jointly,
perhaps without taking on strong
or specific baggage around
how we are then
constrained to think about the bodily
or the cognitive aspects of that.
Modeling blew
up.
And then one other thought was on like
shared action,
including shared planning.
So planning to act together
and about how events or activity
planning in the future
is like an activity
that one person can do or groups can do.
But it's about preparing a context
so that a process can occur.
And sometimes all that's needed
is to send the calendar events invite.
Other times
there might need to be a lot of
work to be done before the event itself.
However, what is the transmission
view on planning
that might be able to describe?
And I think the paper does
an excellent job of saying
that the transmission view is not
refuted by the ecological
and inactive angle.
You said no
transmission, no
communication, no communication.
It's like it's an enabling aspect
of this action orientation
and this focus.
Here's some
other areas that we had written down
from before.
One I'm really
curious to follow up on
is about like language
and maybe the role of
our talking about these issues.
What other media or formats
have you found to be insightful?
Do any and activists
do presentations with
silent films or with objects
that are mailed to you
and you play with or do this?
I mean, how else can we
point at the moon
and not have it be confused
that we're talking finger anatomy?
Read me first.
Dental.
TISON: Okay.
Yeah, I think that that's that's hard to
to
to talk about academic subjects
like this
without
having like an explicitly transmission
view, like appearance of communication
because
this, these kind of interactions
are so far from the basic
interactive activities
that were like the context
of the evolution of communication,
which is what I'm trying to
to explain here.
It's not like you imagine like you
imagine like a tribe somewhere
in the in the place, the person
and like they're they're
they're not trying to explain
academic subjects to each other.
They're trying to do things,
concrete things together.
And that's really
the context
of where
communication evolved and what it
what purpose it served.
But I think that it's hard to
like envision the
academic discussions such as
that when we're I think
now that would be
like that would be more evidence
toward the ecological view
then for the transmission to do.
I don't know if that
that's here, but clearly like
moving your couch together
is a better instance of
and the communication
that takes place in this joint
activity is probably a better example of
our view
than like speaking together
about active and friends
and communication
because this is really a specific
and really
highly complex form of social activity
that is more, more readily described.
For instance, in terms of
of the transmission view, I think.
FRIEDMAN: Yeah, nice.
A lot to say there.
Bleu.
KNIGHT: So I think all of those
things like
even silent
films are also representations, right?
So whether it's a communication
like with communication
or even pointing to
the moon would be like a well,
maybe that would be different.
I don't know.
I like this
idea of communication as an action
that we take.
And I'm not leaving
information transmission
behind in the dirt.
I don't think it
I don't think it needs to go there.
I think.
But but I do think that all actions are
in some way
some kind of information transmission.
So even like like and study
theory of mind.
So I assume you're familiar
with integrated information theory
and the emergent properties
that information can
help us to represent.
And so I think
like in some way even like eating food
like tells the environment
that you're hungry and,
and takes away the food.
And so there's,
there's always some level
of informational exchange,
even if it's
just trivial information exchange,
even if it's not meaningful,
it doesn't create some bigger
emergent thing, right.
FRIEDMAN: Thanks, Bleu Dean.
TICKLES: I think it's an easy again.
I think it's it's I won't say it's easy.
It's really
did a good job of explaining this
and not making it too obtuse.
If you
if you use an example of moving a couch,
the physical manipulation,
it's not hard to extend
that to communication and symbolic
anyplace in the manipulation stays then
then that sort of reinforces
the idea that there is
there a process at hand,
something that we can observe.
But I'm still kind of confused about.
So once that the chair been lifted
or the
the words have come out of my
I heard the expression
because I was watching
the John Bourbaki thing yesterday
and something comes out of my mouth
whole now.
It's it's done.
It's a product.
I mean, we can read, we can read,
submitted or reflect on it or whatever,
but it's there. It's now historical.
And so
that transition from process to product,
I think, is
something that
the manipulation by itself
doesn't explain, have to kind of delink
and see the sort of timelessness
aspect of this.
Carl talks about deep temporal models,
and so I don't know that I'm not sure
how communication manipulation, symbolic
manipulation gets explained
in these deep chemical senses.
And I'm not just talking about
chiseling chiseling it into the stones,
the tablets. Right.
Like there's got to be
another piece to this
that you've looked into.
I mean,
obviously much deeper than I have.
What what what is your sense of that?
Once we get past
the manipulation, processing
and start seeing the the products
pile up?
TISON: Yes. So,
yeah, it's hard to answer
this question, but
that's true of everything.
That is something that happens
at some point.
It's it's it's there
and you can't change it.
So any event, communicative or not,
or like a rug that falls or something
that does that property to know
it's it once
it happens, it's
something to which we can go back.
And I don't know if that's
so, so in the same sense
that if you you talk to say something,
this is something that that does happen
and you can
it's now
a product
and something to which you can allude to
it has influenced the
your cognitive system and then you can
I I'm
I struggled to
to see what was the question exactly.
Well I don't know if that.
TICKLES: One of the things
that you pointed to
right at the very start of your paper
was that what these symbols
that have been manipulated
now set down in this paper
is not the end.
It's the start of something.
This product,
this paper
should be the start of a dialog
or a trialogue or in case a quadra
and it has become something.
Right. So so
it's the back
and forth part
that I find really interesting.
And it's something you spoke
to very clearly
at the very start of your paper.
You didn't say, okay,
so if we get stuck
in the transmission, do
when when I stop talking, that's it.
That's over.
And now we're going to start something
else.
No, you basically said
there's a continuum aspect to this.
It isn't strictly episodic
that we have to look at something
more than just
what Remi says, which I think is that it
brilliant way to start a paper
and an even better way
to start a conversation.
So so there is a product piece to this
and there's a process piece to this.
You put something down
and and a child
will start manipulating it
and then they'll start
manipulating the symbology
that they're applying
or actually
getting associating with that.
So again
you've looked
at that far deeper than I have,
obviously, because
listen to how I ramble. Right.
But I wondered what you're like.
How do you take that
transition piece now
and hold it up to other people
who may
be taking an activist procedure
or to take
more of an instrumentalist approach?
Right.
Because the bottom line
is, it's hard to deny that it's
it's done or it's it's still happening.
But you focused on
the it's still happening.
So what are your thoughts.
TISON: Yeah, I think that
there's with communication
there's a sedimentation.
The Paolo talks about this too
like the symbol we use
then the words that we speak
there's like this.
And then there's also talking about
first all your first order language
and second order language.
And so first order
language is like the flow,
the dynamic
where every interaction is new,
everything is always like on fly
and there's always a transformation
of the linguistic forms that we use.
And the second order language
is like the abstraction
where we can say,
Oh, that's the same word
that has been used
at the same sentence,
that's the same meaning.
And the second order language
is like a and
something that's
added up and
that's an abstraction that's
something traditional linguistic
has really focused on this second,
second order language,
which is like the product of language,
which is like, okay, the language that,
the language that we speak is
a set of sentences, a set of words.
And that's something that
that is
identified at
the level of the second order language.
But when we're speaking
where we're talking,
it's not at this level
that we're doing it.
When we're acting, it's always new.
We always reconfigure being,
we always transforming.
And it's only when we abstract
from this,
like, basic interaction
and some patterns that we see. Okay.
And the second order
at the second level,
there is words,
there's a syntax,
there's some rules that are followed.
But it's not
the real phenomenon.
Language,
phenomenal language
is the first order, and that's the idea.
So maybe that's a way to see like
the real activity is the reader process.
But if we abstract,
if we look back on this process
and we analyze it
and we abstract some parts of it,
then we can see these forms
emerging, these languages,
these words that are used repetitively,
and then we can
apply the product of language.
But in truth,
language is always the process
and that's the shift the terminology
called shift
of not talking about language,
but language in
which is something
that is that an activist
working on language to try to do
that's really brings forward this
this notion of language is always
an activity, always a process
and not like a set of words
instead of symbols that are used.
And these these analysis in terms of
repeatable symbols
is something that we get when we
analyze it
like
after the fact.
And we
see these patterns that are
that are used
that we we get this thickened order.
But when we are doing it
at the fundamental level,
it's really just that process
of continual interaction.
So that's maybe something
to think about.
And there's
something I want to say
really quickly about Bleu
said about the information
and the way in
which information is always present
and that that's true.
That that's
what I allude to
at the end of the paper when I cite
Brian's terms, when I say, yeah,
there's always information
transmission, right?
Just moving in my environment,
there's information that's transmitted.
But yeah, that's exactly the point.
And that's
the idea is
that content is not information.
Information is everywhere,
everywhere, always.
When we when anything happens
in the environment,
in the universe,
there's information
that is created as it transmitted.
But the idea is that information
understood in this
in these terms and uncertainty reduction
notion of information is not sufficient
to explain communication
because there's information
all the way everywhere.
Does that the point that that
that people
who own the transmission
that you think
that they can rely
on this notion of information
to explain it to communication
but it's not that strong
and thus notion of information.
They need the notion of content
to explain
what they want to explain
because, for instance,
the information
that you think about
when they eat, when they wave my arms
like that,
there is information
because there is an exchange
with my environment.
But that's not sufficient
to explain communication
because this information
is everywhere
and communication is not everywhere.
It's a property of certain behaviors
that we have
to be more specific to analyze.
FRIEDMAN: Thank you, Bleu.
KNIGHT: So the
information has to have context, right?
It has to have relevance
for the communication,
for the collective action,
for the collaboration or something.
So so there's no like in an order
for a communication like that
that's contextual.
I don't know.
Imposition needs to exist I think.
FRIEDMAN: Yeah. Nice.
So just a few notes.
I really like
this sedimentation of communication.
It's a really rich, like riverbed
or or rock formation, natural analogy.
That's.
That's concordant
with the ecological perspective
to reflect
how the products of communication
are indeed sequentially layered, the
pen marks on the page can't be erased,
can't undo what was said.
We can't on record,
we can't on transact, on the blockchain,
all these different aspects
and even
including the scientific literature
being appended to continually.
So there's a segmented aspect.
Yet also there's something
that is a process
like the river
that is depositing the sediment.
And then that made me think about
how sometimes
communication is descriptive around
what was or is.
And this may map on to the variational
free energy inference
which is kind of like now casting
or even retro casting.
But once we enter into action mode
and anticipatory or prospective
informing and communicating,
looking forward
to reduce uncertainty of our actions.
Selection is vital for systems
to persist and thrive.
However, as we've explored
in many discussions,
sometimes from a really technical angle,
the introduction of action
into model selection
and just modeling in
general introduces several complexities
how the space of possible
is enumerated and scanned over.
It's a simpler and a different question
to do purely receptive inference
on something about the past,
but to inject one into the present
and embody that present seeing
requires one to act amidst uncertainty
about what
the future of the general process
will be
and the consequences of action,
which are either slightly
or almost entirely unknown so.
The introduction of action
puts us into that realm of expected
free energy
and highlights
all these really interesting dynamics
and how the future is not the past.
But it becomes that way.
Like you get sediment ID, but
this is the pre sedimentation.
There's some dust molecules there
right next to each other in the river.
One of them is going to sediment,
the other one's going to
go out to the Pacific Ocean.
It may not be clear
in that river
which way
the different particles are going to go.
And so that's like
where like all the complexity
and turbulence can be happening.
And so it's a very rich distinction and
something to to really
bring back
about how the past is sediment did,
but there's an openness
in the action consideration
and that's where
planning as inference and joint action
and shared attention, all these features
come into play.
TICKLES: Dean Yeah.
Daniel I don't know if your
if indirectly referring back
to the 47th series
of the live stream, but there it was.
We talked about
was that people
who have
look through in an activist lens
really make fantastic arguments
about let's focus on process,
let's focus on the process.
Apologies
if if you're talking about people who
work in the instrumentalists,
hopefully that'll get answered.
If you're talking about people
walking in
through the instrumentalist lens,
they really to talk about product.
They really want to say
this is a tool
and they argue fantastically for that.
And I think what we tried to do in
the 47 was say,
you're both right,
you both have fantastic arguments.
As an agent who's trying to communicate,
why would we say one
is necessary like we're acting first,
why if we're active and first,
first and foremost,
if we're always trying
to scan
and survey that field of affordances,
why would we drop
one for the other and less
that was necessary?
What isn't part of affordances?
The the ability to option
and be able
to recognize the tool product
and recognize the action in that moment
carrying out that that data thread
which we can now
act further on.
Is that a step Daniel said downstream.
Right.
So again,
I don't think anybody would argue
that activism
and that ecological approach
is hugely important
in order to be able
to generate those affordances
and that maybe,
maybe there's still people
who want to argue
no, if you just bring your toolkit,
all of your all your
your problems will suddenly dissolve.
Or if you just walk into the room,
you'll know how to talk
to all of these people
without really developing that
that sense of, okay, so as you said,
first order and second
order communication, right?
You just walked into the room
and then you reflect later.
So the next time you walk into a room,
maybe you
you come at it
a little differently each time. Right?
So, again, Daniel,
I don't know if you were consciously
or subconsciously referring back
to the last livestream set,
but that's essentially where
I'm kind of that well,
I've been there for a bit now,
but I wonder how you can argue there can
only be one
if we're talking about affordances,
if we're not talking about fine,
it can be one.
But if we're talking about affordances
and we're optioning out,
how can it be less than two?
FRIEDMAN: The menu is not diminished by selecting
what you want for that meal.
You don't rip the rest of the menu
and then also read one one.
Just insight.
I've never heard it
phrase this way,
but it's so interesting
and hopefully as many people
including us some directions is
you said it's hard to discuss
academic subjects
without the transmission view and.
That's just such a fundamental point.
One could take a sort of sociological
critique of, academic discourse
and, well, the practices
and the networks of academics
and the genres
that they write in the venues
and the paywalls
and all of these
different sociological features,
structure, academic discourse to be such
and such a way that can feel lifted
from our first order experience.
And this actually takes an even
more fundamental
angle,
which is,
yes, those sociological features
may be what is explained,
but fundamentally
on on that topic or anything, what is it
about this conceptual or academic mode
of synchronous
and asynchronous discourse?
Just what is it about?
What is it on?
And how can we evolve this
and develop this
to create an ecology of communicate and
to integrate in a new way
for Rmi first and then anyone.
TISON: So yeah,
I think that the
not just the academic discussions
but all our conceptions of education
and learning are influenced
by this transmission view
also because the,
the traditional views of, of,
of education is the notion
that you transmit
a certain knowledge, a certain view,
a certain
content to like the, the student,
you're the teacher
and you have this this content
and you're giving it to the
that's like the tradition,
the traditional view of education.
And there
there's been push back in recent years
in the
fields of communication
and trying to
understand education and apply
more participative
methods of learning
that go against that.
But really,
the view of education
as transmitting knowledge,
I think is really closely connected
to this transmission
view of communication.
And I think that's not
a particularly good
view of applying
pedagogic pedagogic practices.
I think that's that's really limited.
And there's been
the advent
it did for my for our paper
in 2021 to do that.
But yeah,
there's been in recent years
a lot of work in fields of education
in trying to push back again
this against this transmission
view of education
and trying to
put like, yeah,
I think classrooms
that are more interactive
and which there is, there's
active learning from the
from the students
and they're just not just the receiving
and knowledge,
but they're
gaining skills by acting in the in their
in their in their and in an environment,
a learning environment
in which they're agents
and not just patients.
So that's
I think that's something that's
also useful to to to to discuss.
FRIEDMAN: Yes.
We had
some great times
discussing instruction ism
and interaction
ism in the context of skillful
performance and motor commands.
And the discussion was,
are you sending
motor commands representational?
Are they instructions to be carried out
or are they interactions
that are being engaged in
that might
not necessitate
taking a representational list view?
And in this same spirit and strength
of the active inference
framework that we can talk
about patterns across systems
here is instruction
ism and interaction ism
in a very natural
setting of the ecological experience
of learning.
And one can take various
critiques or angles
on like tabula rasa or blank slate.
We don't need to endorse the view.
However, what it implies
quite directly is that there's a canvas
and things are added
sediment on the canvas,
and one can see that
some writing is on the canvas
or it's a different shape, or
those are specifying the metaphor.
But fundamentally the
knowledge accretion model of education,
the opt in model as,
well as the ignorance
destructive model of education,
which is a kind of counterpoint
to we're going to add good knowledge.
And then the shadow
that is we're going to destroy
bad knowledge and unlearn.
Both of those are like working
in the riverbed.
Are we going to sediment this way
or let's modify these sediments.
It's still seeing the product
of education,
which is a totally reasonable focus
for industries and sectors
that are focused
on the products of education,
the products of education
for the student, the certificate
and the
social recognition and status thereof,
or just the outcomes of education
for the system,
like amount of people
with a certain professional training and
what is the river that is sediment thing
or sediments
that can get dropped.
And that's the active term
in education learning by doing
as if even a lecture is doing something,
you're looking, you're hearing,
you're touching.
So
it is quite
an exciting area to explore how
interaction ism
in settings that have been considered
educational,
conventionally or unconventionally,
what the implications are.
And I'm sure that next week
we'll be able to explore
many more implications as we kind of
have crested
one hill
and look towards some implications.
But
how do you communicate differently
with what you know and have done
in philosophy
and science of communication?
TISON: Remmy
I think I'm
really bad at applying my
theory of communication.
I think I,
I give a class in that to come and I,
I always like
I'm angry at myself because I really
like just automatically applies
this really
classical way of, of,
of transmitting knowledge.
And I'm always angry at myself
because I don't apply enough.
I think my,
my, my own ideas about communication.
But the I,
I think I should do
more to, to be a better,
provide better evidence
for my own theory of communication.
FRIEDMAN: It's funny,
I'm sure it'll be
a lifelong process for all of us
because we have priors
that are templated on the forms
that we know.
That's what was and what is
and what maybe
and then there's that expected
free energy
like active communication perspective
and are we going to select
only from yesterday's menu?
Or can new dishes
and new approaches be added
that we may want to select from?
Are there new modalities or approaches
to communication
in educational settings or otherwise
that are now
authorized or
enabled by this perspective?
I'm sure we'll continue to discuss it.
But let's just say this
paper becomes a fundamental
reading for a communications department
or for
early life
learning group like a public school.
What is different
in the short term
with the structural constraints
and opportunities that exist
with someone thinking
and acting differently,
and then over
slower time scales, the coevolution
of those individual
affordances, cognitive and bodily
affordances,
and the kinds of systemic alterations
to the education architecture, then
I know you'll have a thought on that.
TICKLES: Part of what you were speaking to
is just
simply asking as as Remi did
at the beginning of his paper,
and then what happens?
But then
not racing to provide the answers.
It's it's it's essentially
opening.
Opening up the space.
And then
and then what happens
might mean that you
you move out of the classroom
and you
and you take the classroom, migrates to
to the lookout on Mount Royal or you
or you you simply don't intervene.
You you kind of let the ecology
work itself through.
Now, that could be very
scary at first
because of course,
you're supposed to be
the one herding the cats.
But if you let the herd piece of it off
and see what cats do when
you're allowed to sort of
free think,
I think
I don't know that it provides the
the absolute specific answer,
but it will provide you
that joint action opportunity.
If you're
if you're really, truly looking
for affordances
as opposed to specifics.
And and again, I think
even in an academic setting,
I don't think it's I don't think it's
too far of a stretch
to say affordances matter.
And we would like to see
if people can exercise those things.
We just want to get to crazy, right.
FRIEDMAN: Norms and guidelines
for affordances
help.
Don't know what else to say,
but certainly there are things
that one would prefer
not to see occur in a learning setting.
Right.
Easy to enumerate.
And then there are the known
beneficial affordances or phenomena
and then part of interaction ism
seems to leave the unknown unknown
quadrants open
and to allow for
individual or for collective outcomes
that are surprising and maybe not
explicitly navigated towards or
planned for.
But how to leave
the unknown unknowns open
while derisking unknowns
and knowns is a challenge.
And so again, it's natural to see where
in the de-risking imperative
we de-risk
everything.
And that introduces like
second order risks.
And it closes the door
on what may have even been the purpose.
I mean, what's the safest car,
the one that doesn't move
in that one limited local optimization
of like reducing the number
of high speed collisions
or something like that?
Yes, Remmy.
TISON: And so on that topic,
I think there's
Bloomberg in the world
and give us time to talk about
an optimal grip on the field of.
I didn't see it,
I think, but their work was a great,
inspiring inspiration
for for my own work.
So they talk about an optimal grip
on the on that field of affordances.
And there's like
you're always trying to stay
in the point where you're there is like
the relevant
affordances are open to you,
but you stay,
you stay at the same time
open to switching to other F audiences.
And you're trying to,
in that process of interaction
with your field of affordances,
continually minimize
your own free in there in G.
But there is there's risk in that.
So there's
the idea that the example that they give
is the boxer
who was trying to maintain
a certain distance to its opponent,
because at that distance
it's the boxer is fighter.
It cannot reach with its punches.
If it's too close,
maybe there's less impact
and maybe it's more
open to it to be in it.
So there's like this optimal distance
to which the boxer as light,
flexible and multiple opportunities
that it can
the boxer can take.
And I
think that's
what we were always trying to do.
We're trying
to get to this optimal grip,
as did the field of affordances
in which
there's multiple affordances, that
forward energy minimization,
and that we want to take that.
And that's obviously
something that can be hard to do.
But we have
through our skillful interaction with
the environment, we learn these kinds of
of gradients.
Where should we go in the
in our environment
in order to find these optimal groups?
And like you're speaking about car,
I guess depending on your skill,
you might want different car
to get this optimal grip on the
on the, on the road.
If you're like a fast driver
who likes to go
go really fast,
you might want a faster car.
But if you go too far
and you're getting an accident,
so there's depending on
our skills, there's different
optimal grips on the road feel develop
audience and something
was really afraid to go might go with it
like really slow car and that would be
it's that person's
optimal grip on the road.
That would be the
this would provide for for this person.
So that made me think about that.
So some comments on optimal grip.
Thanks for bringing in yellow
all work it's
it's really nice
that that was brought in
even several years ago
into the active inference literature
and if we're imagining
tactile grip actual prevention
if we're not in a grip
strength competition
where one might just
monotonically prefer more grip,
if we were like on a playgrounds
and we're going to be
swinging among bars,
then the optimal grip has to satisfy
being able to keep us off the hot lava.
FRIEDMAN: But also it's not permanent.
And there's like a level of engagement
that is not as strong
as we could possibly
grasp, but gets the job
done, keeps us in the air,
and lets us easily
and without repetitive stress,
like grab the next bar.
So how might that be reflected
in some of the formal isms
of active inference?
While for expected
and variational free energy,
there are two terms.
One is reflecting
a divergence minimization
and one is keeping the door open with
about future outcomes.
So in
that balance is
like the divergence
minimization of the boxer.
But then also there is something
about keeping it open
and then
it makes me wonder about optimal grip
with some of these educational
and academic ideas.
What is the optimal
in a given context of thermodynamics?
Could it be the optimal grip
in a easygoing
chill, qualitative conversation to know
that thermodynamics has to do with
things like temperature?
And now we're going to talk
about something adjacent to it.
That was just one
bar on the playground to jump among.
And so what does optimal grip
and feel like
and what are the ecologies that support
different individuals, optimal grip
on different concepts so that
people can be
engaging and interacting in a
way that is natural and and
seamless for them.
Yeah. Remi.
TISON: I think there's a case where did that
usually to get to talking
about the tactile grips
there can be an optimal grip in
in that sense.
And I think
in the communicative context,
we can also see, for instance, the
the case where we're in
that we talked about example
of moving furniture together.
There is this
this optimal grip
where, okay,
you're holding the couch
and you can feel it slipping
sometimes and you're like,
oh dear, I must get a better grip.
But in that case,
you have an interactive component
and you have a communicative component
because you can see
when you're feeling your grip
slips, you can see stuff
to the other person, to okay, so
to the other person can stop moving
and then you can get a better grip
on the on the couch.
So this aspect that
the idea that we tried to
to put in
in the paper
when we were talking
about cooperative communication is that
there can be an optimal grip
from a collective,
from an interactive perspective.
And communication
is a way of achieving
that, of achieving an optimal grip
by a group of individuals under
under the context of their
their joint action.
And so, for example,
if I'm
moving a couch with somebody
and I feel my grip slipping,
I can say, oh, stop, because it will
it will stop the couch from moving,
and then it will help me
get a better grip
in the literal
and figurative sense on the couch
so that we can further advance
our joint action of moving that couch.
FRIEDMAN: Thank you, Bleu.
KNIGHT: So something else like where
is an interesting place where we have
grip, where
we don't always think about it
is in the in the mental capacity.
So like when you talk about overthinking
so like you think something
you can under think underprepared
and then you can also overthink.
So there's also this optimal space.
And just as a practitioner of meditation
for a long time,
when you're meditating on something,
it's the same,
so like it's like this over
focus, like you have to hold it
there, the object of your meditation.
But like if you squeeze too tight,
like if you focus on it too intently
goes away, it pops up.
And lots of things are like,
I mean,
even if you literally grip something,
if you squeeze it too tight,
it will pop out of your hand.
Just that the force
and the philosopher's acts
make it that way.
So I just wanted to bring that up.
FRIEDMAN: Thank you.
Bleu one.
No, on the couch moving example.
It's quickly
become our favorite example.
We should definitely do some
visuals next time.
It's it's an
interesting example
because the communication
candy representational and linguistic,
we don't have enough room for my right
hand to come through this doorway.
It's very transmission view compatible,
but also there's
a direct, continuous time
communication
through the mechanics of the couch
that are synchronously
being experienced in real time
and mediated through artifacts
and through the niche itself.
Linguistic communication
has a linear, sequential
and turn taking aspect.
Active listening is a practice that
from the point of view
of the active listener,
whether they speak or not,
brings that real time and continuous
engagement to the discourse.
Even if they're listening to a recording
or whether they're participating or
listening in a conversation.
However
it, feels like something
really important to unpack
as we look towards
the linguistic direction
to differentiate settings
where like through digital stigma g
and note taking
or through physical objects
like a rowing team
or the moving the couch,
there's a mediation
through the environments continuously
as opposed to
something like a correspondence
chess game or a phone call
where there's a linear
turn taking sedimentation,
even though there may still be
a continuous unfolding of experience
for the agents.
So that is a very rich area to look at.
Dean
Yeah, you're
just you're jumping in
and saying things that I want to say.
So obviously the
some sort of substantive
simpatico is going on
communication wise.
But I was going to say,
I was going to kind of
now I'm going to build off what you said
and what you said.
One of the things that we used to always
bring to people's attention
in terms of their field of affordances,
that when you're
having to explain something, you have
to take your time.
TICKLES: You have to slow down.
I was working with younger people.
You have to slow down.
But the also the other part of it is
you have to know when to hit the hand up
reaction button in the zoom call.
You have to time your take
for full effect.
So you have to know
both of those relativities
when we're talking about communication
because if you are,
you can show your passion
by constantly
interrupting another person
and actually do yourself a disfavor.
So the first thing was always slow down.
The second thing was always think about
when you're putting up your hand,
think about when it's your turn.
Allow sometimes
for there to be a pregnant pause.
I know Daniel's very gifted at this.
There's lots and lots of times
as the moderator,
he could just fill in the space.
But he's really, really good
at sometimes
letting the communication happen
when nothing is said.
So I'm going back to what he was asking
earlier is
can we signal something
by not saying something?
And I didn't jump in then, but
I was kind of hoping to be able
to explain that before
we have to sign off today,
because that's a perfect example
of actually doing the signaling
without manipulating the symbols
per se.
FRIEDMAN: Interesting stuff.
Does anyone have any
final thoughts in this one?
Yes, please. Renny.
TISON: Yeah.
Just quickly, the the the idea that
there's like a still in the
when to intervene speak too much speak
not enough.
It's it's like this
the dimension that went through
what is called pragmatics in
in in linguistics.
And there's a really clear
of the notion of an optimal grip.
Again, in terms of distance,
there's not an appropriate distance
to which you
you must send to your interlocutor.
And that varies in function of culture.
So if you're really
so it's in some culture
and some for some person
it can be like really close
to you and your income for public for
but for them
it might be their, their optimal grip
in this communicative interaction
for their for others.
Maybe your, your, you must be faster.
But then if you're too far, then
you might you're bad
less, less
and less good
understanding of what
this person is saying.
So there's this optimal group
also in the pragmatics
of the interaction that yes,
I think that was a good point.
FRIEDMAN: Optimal grip in space and time
and meaning, many spaces for.
A conversation.
Are you intimately familiar
and perturbing and six inches away
or are you yelling purely
strategic, impersonal information
from across the fields?
A lot of different ecologies,
a lot of different agents.
So a lot of different communications,
blue or green,
if you have any other
thoughts otherwise.
That brings us to a very nice end
of 48 one,
and I'm
sure it'll be a great discussion
to continue next week.
KNIGHT: Thanks for providing us
with such beefy, juicy
stuff to talk about.
I really enjoyed the paper
having you here. It's great.
TICKLES: Thank you.
Completely concur.
Review is a fantastic paper
and as I said,
there's nothing that I find
more intriguing when somebody writes
something down
not as providing all the answers,
but as opening up
all all these questions
that we've been able to share today.
So I'm very I'm
very happy
that you were able to join us.
FRIEDMAN: All right.
Thank you all.
See you next week.